un choc indien de district ce dimanche
26 mars le voisin FC en jaune recevait
bailler noisy les deux équipes dans le
top 5 du classement vice toujours la
montée en fin de saison dans ce match à
Angers les joueurs locaux sont plus
dominateurs mais n'arrive pas à
concrétiser leurs occasions ils se font
finalement surprendre par les bleus sur
cette action A0 ce sera le score à la
pause
[Musique]
on domine après on manque de tranchant
dans les 30 derniers mètres parce qu'on
a les situations sans grosses occasion
au final mais quand on a 80% de
possession de balle on peut pas se
permettre de de perdre un zéro à la
mi-temps tout simplement on n'a pas le
ballon où sont pas et on est solidaire
on est bloc bas après je disais pas
trouver très dangereux à part sur coup
de pied arrêté et nous on est sorti deux
trois fois on marque on marque avant la
pose ça nous fait du bien et après voilà
on est dans la lignée de ce qu'on fait
depuis le début de saison au retour des
vestiaires les vicinois accélèrent et
trouvent la faille sur cette action un
partout de son côté baïloisis subie dans
cette seconde période et terminera la
rencontre à 10 après une expulsion en
infériorité numérique et sur le point de
plier les visiteurs arrivent à se
projeter vers l'avant en fin de match
sur cette action et marque score final
de 1
[Musique]
gros soulagement on a subi un deuxième à
discontron on prend on prend un rouge
assez tôt et voilà comme je vous ai dit
on a su être solidaire on est resté blog
bas et quand on est sorti on a marqué
voilà tout simplement dur à l'image de
notre saison je pense qu'il faut deux
tiers de but et il marque le deuxième
juste après qu'on est tiré sur le poteau
ils sont réussies pas nous et on perd de
1 voilà franchement à l'image de la
saison n'est pas efficace ils le sont
ces saisons comme ça c'est comme ça
après cette victoire Bailly noisy peut
toujours espérer monter en fin de saison
ce sera plus compliqué pour le voisin FC
le dimanche 2 avril voisin recevra
l'e-maili jouera à domicile contre Le
Chesnay
[Musique]